good evening everyone welcome to the
first ever reading by the winners of by
the first-ever winners of the wyndham
campbell literature prizes i'd like to
welcome you all to the yale art gallery
tonight we're really thrilled to have
all of the prize winners here in this
room everyone is going to do a brief
10-minute reading we're going to be
reading from all three categories
fiction nonfiction and drama and the
idea behind this reading I think was
really to allow you to hear the actual
physical human voices of all these
writers that were celebrating here this
week and to have those voices echo off
of one another in ways that there are
they've already been doing throughout
the last couple of days in various talks
and panel discussions that have been
going on and and we thought it would be
a really great opportunity to have you
hear them reading from their great
artwork and having that be the center of
the evening so before we get started I'd
like to introduce all of our prize
winners and give them a hand Naomi
Wallace in drama Johnny Steinberg and
nonfiction
Tom McCarthy and fiction Tarell Alvin
McCraney in drama jeremy scahill and
nonfiction Zoe Wickham in fiction
stephen adly Girgis in drama Adina
Hoffman in nonfiction and james salter
and fiction that will be the reading
order this evening so please welcome
Naomi Wallace and we're going to read a
very short play called 11 short sleep
and this wonderful actor is agreed to do
it with me i'm doing the stage direction
this is a smile haliti playwright and
actor and the play takes place after
2006 a young Lebanese man Bashir early
twenties dressed casually is digging a
hole in the ground with a shovel he digs
at different times during the scene but
often breaks for periods while speaking
to us at the end of her body yes at the
end of her body there are six spinning
fingers called spinnerets which make a
spinning machine so intricate nothing
can match it these fingers or spinning
tubes having tiny holes at the end of
each one through which spins the thread
spills I like that word and I say spills
as a spider's web is actually liquid
until it comes into contact into contact
with the air
on the feet are tiny claws to guide the
thread three different kinds and the
pilots let me tell you about the pilots
when they are very young they climbed to
the highest points they can find and
then turn to face the wind and there are
various kinds of wind today for instance
is the kind of wind that the shapes of
jets leave behind when the Jets
disappear their silver hangs in the air
there cold fuel floats like blue threads
over the city nothing to do with beauty
everything to do with precision for the
spider then stands on tippy toe raises
its opposite for soma its abdomen or end
as high is it can in the air and sends
out a stream of silk from its youthful
spinnerets the air takes up the thread
and the spinner pays out its line until
it's long enough to tug the spider and
hold its weight then the spider let's go
and pilots the craft through the breeze
and the spider is not at the mercy of
the wind but can hole in its thread or
lengthen it to the rise and fall in the
air this tiny perfect aircraft may
travel long distances even out to sea
perhaps to end up on foreign soil or if
unlucky to spin its thread on a wave a
wave that's how they came for us wave
after wave the pilots covering the
ground covering the ground with for
covering the ground with four million
covering the ground with four million
cluster munitions covering our streets
our roofs the bomb let's lay their hard
fruit in the broken road and they
weren't made not by God as the spiders
are but by hands soul during cutting
screwing polishing testing and I studied
I studied up until the moment of
spinnerets the spiders and their wonders
of all the studies I could have chosen
at beirut University I chose entomology
because spiders have eight eyes arranged
in two rows on the front of their heads
eight eyes and
jeanette 8 opportunities to witness an
event from a different angle it was
summer in the year two thousand and six
the Jets took off out just outside Tel
Aviv and Haifa perhaps even Jerusalem
and my enemy my brother the pilot pulled
the night smooth and tight across our
garden while my sister Radha examined an
end on her finger she held the creature
up to my face get lost I said he holds
up the blade of the shovel and talks to
it as though it were his sister get lost
Radha I'm reading I have exams tomorrow
little girl you know nothing about
spiders and soon I will know everything
we were cruel to each other my
eight-year-old sister and I because we
loved each other absolutely I was
turning the page of my book on spiders
the sirens were sounding the leaflets
were dropping the kindness of warnings
you are ordered to evacuate your
villages immediately we had no weapons
in our home but the Wonder the wonder of
those tiny spinning tubes of the liquid
of contact with air it was the second
raid my mother couldn't get back home
she was with her mother safe across town
my dear father was on our roof his legs
were at the bottom of the stairs and
Radha had an aunt at the end of her body
at the end of her body on the end of her
finger and she was singing or weeping
singing or weeping and I told her to
stop but she just kept on namal Israel
nameless fear Allah hi fig little ant
little and God lives in you take me to
your home the sky is no longer blue I
said he speaks to the shovel blade again
shut up sing about spiders you stupid
girl not ants not ants ants can't be
pilots the noise of jets is silence
until they are done and when they are
done grace close
it's door I was going to be an expert on
insects I read all the books in English
I knew the Latin names for silence for
silly girls for the numbers that
surround the number eight the bomb that
was falling towards our house the bomb
that was fabricated in Nevada or
Wisconsin or Indiana was dreamt into
being through a good day's labor and
good day's work and then we were hit I
wish I had been born a spider chela
Sarah epigastric furrow spigots such
eloquent names for small pieces of the
body and to have eight eyes eight eyes
to see the world from different vantage
points in that half second before death
when the sky is clear as cold weather
when the Sun is tiny in our throats and
we kneel at our graves but cannot warm
the dirt cannot gather our pieces again
or explained absence of the love of
strangers and we have never met only
what they have touched my sister had had
and I we couldn't hold it together no we
couldn't hold it together our bodies
went in different directions we were
dispersed yes we kicked the bucket we
bit the dirt we batten down the hatches
know that last one is wrong maybe
cloaked he now puts down the shovel and
speak sharply to the grave he's been
digging oh it wasn't like that was it
hey I've been to university sister I
know a thing or two you've got no sense
of humor kid then you tell me what what
we like on with that he listens to his
sisters answer for some moments you are
a brat he listens again alright alright
hada says she has eight eyes even though
she didn't go to university even though
she never studied spiders and she says
she saw eight things
one that we were both of us standing
side by side to clear arm full of water
to that when the bomb dropped down into
us our water left from its hold three
that the wind caught us as our liquid
made contact with the air for that we
paid out our lines five we paid out our
lines of gossamer threads with the time
we had left to us six that there was a
tug at our lines seven so we let
ourselves go what is the eighth thing
you saw hada huh she says she won't tell
me because I raised my voice he sits on
the edge of the grave and examines his
work I've made a good hole though not
perhaps just for us not just for myself
and Radha all right you can have one of
my special ink pens if you tell me about
just one with the eighth I my sister
says she did not see anything with the
eighth I in that moment she heard a song
how can you hear with your eyes silly oh
that's how though I am forbidden to tell
you yet but I can tell you what she says
she heard spider spider little boy oh
sorry my my ears are no longer so good
from the blast it's not boy I try again
anka boot angebote sides rear mean I ish
feeha eunuch spider spider little joy
who lives in your eyes it was so long
ago it was just yesterday eight times I
so love eight times love saw me the end
thank you
Johnny steinberg thanks i'm going to
read from a forthcoming book called a
man of good hope Assad Abdul ice it's
upset me at a table in the company
gardens around us elderly white men are
playing chess my notebook is opened on
the table my pen in my hand I'm asking
us sad about the Quran district of
Mogadishu where he spent the first seven
or eight years of his life he says he
remembers so little it doesn't matter i
say instead of trying to remember just
tell me what comes into your head when
you think of Mogadishu so artists
thought comes to me he's wearing a
body-hugging yellow hoodie and skinny
blue jeans and in this tight attire he
seems to me not just tall and thin but
elongated each part of him his nose his
cheeks his palms and his fingers his
torso appear to have beans ever so
caringly stretched the result is elegant
it occurs to me that he isn't sitting at
Cape Town's point of origin the gardens
around us were planted 358 years ago
almost to the day here as i said on very
old ground while he himself is so new
and so decidedly unwelcome in his
slender fingers is a twig I think he
picked it up while we strolled up from
the library now he snaps it in half and
draws it to his nose his eyebrows rious
with surprise and he smells it again
amazing he says from the moment I saw it
lying on the ground I knew what the
smell would remind me of and he begins
to tell me how he made ink he was seven
years old he thinks a student at a
madrassa preparing the charcoal mixture
into which he would dip his pin in order
to copy out the Quran to bind the inky
says you need the sap from an a Greek
tree you snap Herbert a branch with
pinched fingers and with pinched fingers
tease out the juice allowing it to drip
into the charcoal and water while
stirring the mixture you absent mindedly
put your fingers to your nose you
breathe in deeply ah the smile in his
face is wistful and intense and I think
that I have an inkling of where he has
gone
he knows that I'm still here that at the
table next to us men are playing chess
but he is also elsewhere and he is
savoring it free understands that it can
only last a few seconds he is reeled
back more than 20 years with the Twiggy
is found in the company gardens he is
reliving the Forgotten high for it is
clear from the expression on his face
that the SAP of the agree is narcotic I
feel a whim rising I know that if I
think about it even for a moment I'll
find a reason to back off so I don't
think about it the man who idly snaps
open a twig and is transported back so
vividly so powerfully to another world
is a man about whom I was write a book
there and there might tell him that I
will give him seven thousand Rand to
start his new business a week after
giving him the money I go and see him in
his Shack int in town on the outskirts
of Cape Town he has cut a hole in one of
his walls and covered it with a wire
meshing behind it is a stool and behind
that ceiling higher shelves filled with
cigarettes and crisps and tinned food
and bags of mini meal I do not share
with him at first what I'm hoping for I
begin to go to see him twice a week we
sit on his bed and talk for an hour or
so than I leave at the end of my third
visit i asked whether he would consider
the prospect of my writing a book about
his life I tell him that were he to
agree to this I would ask for a lot of
his time two mornings a week said maybe
for as long as a year I would travel to
the places he has lived or least two
those two which travel is possible and I
would try to find people who once knew
him I wish to see the houses in which he
slept and to walk the streets he walked
when the book is published as say I will
offer him twenty-five percent of
royalties I give him a sense of the sort
of Sanders would probably turn out to be
I tell him not to answer me now but to
give it thought driving back to Cape
Town on the motorway my feelings are
mixed I'm excited back at the University
of Cape Town I will not even stop in at
my office I will go straight to the
library and take out four or five of the
most raped two books on Somalia and I
will bury myself in them I also feel
uneasy he is a man in need I am certain
that he will say yes I true I've
extended him a lifeline but I've also
helped him open a cash business in a
lawless place
his life was his life is worth much less
than it was two weeks ago I find myself
making a mental note I must ask him
where Cape Town smileys bury their dead
I'd thought that the 7,000 rad would
free him to talk to me one can hardly
ask a man who scroungers daily for work
to take off two days a week to sift
through his memories but his new shop
brings to our meetings troubles of a
different eelke his wife can work the
counter while he speaks to me but she
knows little English and no closer or
for cons and so I said increasingly
adept at all three must be on hand
sometimes I accompany him to mitchells
plain town center or de Belleville or to
a chaw he must do in the center of town
but on the whole he witnessed conduct
her interviews in shouting distance of
his business at first we meet in his
Shack i sat on the edge of his bed and
here in a plastic chair but he is
uncomfortable with the arrangement he
fiddles incessantly with his hands at
the slightest sound outside he cocked
his head and listens an hour into our
second interview he has had enough he
tells me briskly that we cannot meet in
his Shack any longer and it's just that
we moved to my car and so day after day
that is where we meet I sit in the
driver seats he in the passenger seats
man look my notebook passing between us
is I record his test me in shorthand and
he draws pictures of the scenes that he
describes i'm parked parallel to his
Shack no more than a meter or two from
the mesh covered hole through which his
wife serves his customers each person
who comes to buy from him brushes
against my car door he tells me that he
wants it this way because his shack is
too small but it isn't it's a perfectly
comfortable space in which to talk far
more convivial in fact than a car I
wonder what his real reasons are and why
he wishes to keep them concealed it
comes to me slowly as our time together
stretches into a rhythm and as the
rhythm begins to him its meaning more
bluntly it comes to me once I and by of
the bizarreness and the perversity of
our meetings I am a citizen of my
country and the many strangers around me
are aware of this one of them might
choose to shoot a bullet into my head
but he knows that a machinery will kick
into motion and people will come looking
for him I and those around me are in an
orbit together where
all aware of the rules as sad does not
move within this orbits he stands
outside of it for the rules do not apply
to him his shop filled with cash every
day and he knows that his neighbors know
that was somebody to shoot him in the
head and take his money the machinery of
state would stutter reflexively into
motion and then grinds to a halt I come
to see that this knowledge shapes his
life in his every decision the
imperative to be free tussles with the
imperative to be safe on his shoulders
rests the incessant burden of dodging
his own murder it is our third week
together we are sitting in my car
talking turn on the ignition he says I
look at him the moment ago he was deep
in childhood memory his head bowed his
hand running habitually over the
dashboard now he is sitting bolt upright
and his eyes are fixed on my rearview
mirror I turn around don't he says just
start the ignition I obey then I adjust
my side mirror to see what he sees a
couple of hundred meters back three
young men the hoodies low over the
eyebrows are walking towards us I'm not
afraid I'm certain that they will soon
turn left or right and head down in
other Street there are simply 3 shack
settlements Shack settlement residence
going about their business after all
everybody under a certain way age wears
a hoodie Assad's allies neatly folded
among the clothes in his Shack we wait I
begin to feel Assad's fear as if it is a
virus as if has jumped off him and sunk
into my skin and is now coursing through
my veins this moment is so very
productive while a part of him is in my
blood I can understand I can know why he
insists on meeting in my car more
important I know the calculations he is
made when he allowed me into his life
you get scared every time I visit I say
yes you applies his eyes still fixed on
the men behind us you worry that a white
man and a good car attracts men with
guns and that you and your family are
much more and safe when I'm around I
worry about that so much he says and you
insist that we meet in the mornings
because that is when gangster sleep
that's right and you want to meet in the
car so that you can see danger coming in
the shack you reply as you can see
nothing the first you see of them is the
gun in your face by now the three young
men have walked right past us and we are
watching their backs as they
Pierre I turn off the ignition and pick
up my pen and notebook I do not want to
tell him what else I think I now know
saying it out loud would be dangerous it
would force us to examine our
Arrangements in its naked perversity
would make it hard for us to continue
I'm imagining the calculations he is
made he very much wants to hang on to me
for I'm a person from the other side a
person who travels within the orbit of
the law who knows when he might need
such a person to come to his aid perhaps
tonight but to keep our acquaintance he
must sit for hours alongside me and
remember his past otherwise I will lose
interest and disappear and he must do
this remembering he was do this
remembering in the vicinity of his home
and family for he cannot wander from his
new business so often and for so long
yet the routine of my recurring presence
he believes is bound to attract men with
guns and so he juggles he draws close to
the parts of me that brings safety while
diluting as best he can the parts that
bring danger hence my car between
October 2010 and September 2011 we spend
many hours there while his internal I
appears into his childhood the eyes and
I the side of his nose scan the streets
thanks
Tom McCarthy thank you I was going to
read a passage from my first published
but remainder but I just attended a
really excellent dialogue between a
dinner and and Johnny and and and and
Jeremy about some really jet lags I
can't even remember my own name about
about archives and so I want to dialogue
with that dialogue by reading a passage
from my last book see um about archives
which it seems to me always have to do
with death so the year is 1913 and
surgeon Sophie brother and sister are
growing up on the family estate versoix
where their father runs a day school
food for the Deaf a day school for deaf
children Sophie teenage sophie is a
budding naturalist she spends lots of
time in her little lab on the estate
extracting chemicals from plants and
insects she'll eventually poison herself
with one of these chemicals their father
Simeon is an aura list he teaches deaf
children to speak he's very much modeled
on alexander bell the inventor of the
telephones father who did exactly this
and part of his practice involves making
recordings of these children as they
learn to speak partly as an aid and
partly to kind of as a showcase to show
to to show off his achievements to you
know prospective future parents of the
day school um Bodnar is the name of the
gardener who is mute he has a deformed
mouth
the Attic draws them back again and
again on rainy days Serge and Sophie go
there to fiddle with their fathers
archive he has stacks of old recordings
lamp blackened glass phone autograph
plates and rolls of paper bearing
scratch marks laid down by voices
moaning from deaf bodies before either
of them was born zinc master discs that
cut in the final years of the last
century and the first view of this
appeared to surge like coins of some
exotic currency gone out of circulation
miniature round islands of arrested time
the surfaces of the zinc disk gives off
disks give off a faint smell of beeswax
beeswax overlaid with some sharp
chemical chromic acid Sophie tells him
when she sees him wrinkling his nose at
one I've got a whole file of it in my
lab the cylinders they find beside these
are formed entirely of wax solid brown
columns of the stuff whose smooth molded
surfaces have been defaced by networks
of engravings strange meshed graffiti
Sathyan serge can play these back thanks
to an old edison phonograph they find
gathering dust among them selecting
recordings at random some are in
labelled cardboard tubes are there's a
loose and unmarked they slide the
cylinder on to its mandrel and wait for
the sound to trickle out most of the
cylinders contains sequences of letters
spoken out aloud repeatedly b-b-but
bubba b t.t.t.t tata tea is SS b the
voices those of day school pupils now
alumni manifest varying degrees of
distorted pneus and a tonality
the letters warp and morph as they
progress they gather certain rhythms
patterns of repetition or half
repetition then just when it seems that
there's a logic to their sequences they
break and relinquish them again surgeon
Sophie fall into the habit of putting on
these recordings each time they're in
the Attic a mechanical background chorus
to their various antics up there
sometimes they play on a newer Berliner
gramophone not cylinders but discs
exhibition plates their father had
printed to showcase his students ability
to enunciate whole phrases or manage
entire conversations after setting the
disk gently on its turntable and
cranking the Berliners handle they lead
the needle down towards the narrow
groove with the assiduous pneus of
Surgeons guiding knives back to
incisions made on previous occasions
then returned to their tasks while
random on our dialogues model exchanges
between infant shopkeepers and customers
or passengers and trained guards waft
around them often when a disks come to
its end they let it run on playing and
replaying the same stretch of silence
silence which in fact is anything but
silent bursting as it is with a crackle
and snap that conjures up for surge the
image of Bodnar's deformed mouth opening
and closing many Bodnar's mouths
repeated side by side in rows that fill
the attics air and extend out beyond its
roof and walls sometimes while Sophie's
busy copying plants he props his head
right up against the gramophone and
watches the needle running through it
trench snagging and jumping constantly
as though locked in hostile struggle
with the furrow the discs made of a
thick black material it's shellac
sofiane forms him when he asks her one
overcast Monday made from secretions of
the lac
the Lac bug surg asks what's it lacking
lack no k she says I've got one of those
in my lab as well that's rayna's voice
she's right the disc he's come across
this morning contains not phrases but a
passage of verse which spoken in a
child's unbroken voice seemed strangely
fitting for its newfound auditorium be
not afeared the aisle is full of noises
sounds and sweet airs that give delight
and hurt not sometimes a thousand
tangling instruments will hum about mine
ears and sometimes voices that if I then
had waked after long sleep will make me
sleep again the speaker rainer spent a
year or so at versoix a half german boy
who lost his hearing than his life to a
cancer that developed in his ear search
saw the cancer one day it was bulbous
like a set of roots buckling the organs
in a chamber upsetting the delicate
architecture of it swirls and plateaus
from beneath the skin surface while a
moss like coat over grew it from above
surge moves his head round and looks
down into the Berliners reproducing horn
it's brass has turned slightly green
with time the tube darkens as it narrows
then disappears into the sound box
listening to rainer surge thinks of
entrances to caves and wells of worm and
foxholes rabbits burrows and all things
that lead into the earth thanks
Terrell Tarell Alvin McCraney let's see
if I can navigate it can you hear me
alright so I'll use that a little bit
like as an ambient sound catcher because
otherwise I'll have to crouch down and
get my eagle on and you don't want that
I'm going to read from to poor parts of
the brother/sister place because there
are three of them and if I read all of
them we'd be here all night so this
one's from Marcus or the secret of sweet
which is yeah Marxist or the secret of
sweet and this is shawn tae Yoon talking
to her best friend Marcus okay you got
that great are you sweet Marcus Marcus
stone steps back Marcus it seems like
you ain't never gonna confess it surely
not to OSHA you know she liked you right
you know she think we best friends
better love us but I OSHA I'm just your
friend are you sweet I wonder where that
comes from calling somebody sweet they
must have passed it down to us down
through slavery say the slave owners get
pissed if they find out they slaves got
the gay love that means less children
less slaves less think about it Marcus
where else it gonna come from you think
we just naturally mad at gay folk come
on imagining how they got down back then
round here [ __ ] think they got it hard
on the down low what about back then two
slaves one dark one light one house the
other field and they see each other one
day that sparkle in the eye they begin
to gather together when they can hide
their love from the
light dark kisses in the midnight hour
with shackles for love bracelets and
chains for promise rings one night Massa
come up on them in their secret spot cuz
some handkerchief had other slave
jealous 'holy went and told i seent
so-and-so house and so-and-so feels laid
down together in the quarter Marcus you
think slaves was snitching Shantay you
hmm knows eNOS is primordial snitchin
inevitable master tie and tether the
lovers in front of everybody talking
about sending a message placing weights
on their private portions lashing into
the skin that they just held too tight
moments ago skin that was just kiss now
split up from the last of this white
man's hands and when the wounds are
right he run down and get some sugar
probably not probably pour it on it
don't sting as bad as salt but it gets
sticky and melt and sing in the Southern
Sun see sweetness draw all the bugs and
infection to the source sweetness is
harder to wash away it become a Lass's
in all the heat and blood and is that
you Marcus you scare somebody go and
catch you are you sweet so that's that
one
this next piece is from the brother
sighs and I warn you has graphic
language slam since day one day one
you've been [ __ ] up and not just the
other day when you were standing here
looking all lost and stupid all high on
life and a little bit of weed that the
Food Lion won't find in your piss naw
hell naw from day one aren't Elegua
stopped taking us to church I stopped
going because I want to go in the first
place but you kept getting up in the
morning you kept getting up every
Sabbath and going down to the river to
wash your [ __ ] sins away and
everybody like look at little sighs
taking up the cross with Jesus look at
him he only nine look at that devotion
for Jesus you should do like your
brother Oh goon you should go down to
the church like juicy you know what I
wanted to say [ __ ] that [ __ ] and the
church I was jealous I want it to be you
for a moment Little sighs I wanted to be
just like my little brother until me and
Elegua found you using the money you
were stealing from collection in a crap
game yeah yeah and then everything
turned everything turns spun right round
and landed on me everybody like he only
nine if you would have been a better
role model for him okuni would have
acted like that if I if I aren't elegua
sealed it that miserable old ass lady
she she say your mama would have been so
disappointed in you letting your brother
go like that Yemaya would have hated you
failing her Oh goon letting your brother
go letting you go I let you go I let you
go I I got one image of my momma in my
mind and it puts with me at night she's
standing there out by the water my
mama's standing out looking out looking
out towards the Gulf belly full of you
she's standing there holding my hand
tight tight tight just her
and the water us that's all I got left
on my mama and and you are in that
picture you are a part of all I got left
[ __ ] so I held on from that day I
gripped onto your ass and I pushed you
through school I forced you up and out
whatever the [ __ ] you I did it I burned
my chance at anything so that I didn't
leave you behind I went running after
you and ahead of you always hoping that
I could catch you or keep my grip on you
or catch you before anyone else did but
no matter what I did no matter if I
thought you were fine i thought you were
gonna be okay somehow you would slip
through and [ __ ] up and [ __ ] up and [ __ ]
up and when you [ __ ] up somehow i
[ __ ] up somehow there is no escaping
you you say to me you ain't never been
in the pen [ __ ] whenever you fall
everybody look at me like I [ __ ]
pushed you that is my life sentence
that's my lock down all my life I've
been carrying your sins on my back and
not you out there in a car that i souped
up and popped off only so they can find
you in it with a pound of [ __ ] powder
cocaine what thank
jeremy scahill
that that that was that was so amazing
and intense this whole experience of
being here with all of you has just been
surreal I'm sure many of you had never
heard of me I hadn't heard of many of
you but I am blown away by each and
every one of you and I'm just really
honored to be with you all I i'm going
to read two little sections from my
latest book dirty wars which tracks the
rise of these elite covert US military
units that run what the administration
calls the targeted killing campaign
around the world but in many ways it
really amounts to an assassination
campaign so that there are about five or
six stories woven together in the book
its narrative nonfiction there are
characters in it and one of the main
characters is the american-born cleric
anwar awlaki who was the first u.s.
citizen targeted for assassination on
orders of the President President Obama
without ever having been charged with a
crime and never been in he had never
been indicted and he was not on an act
of battlefield fighting against US
soldiers so the case itself is a test of
the Constitution and many other issues
but part of the reason why this story
fascinated me so much is that the u.s.
didn't just kill Anwar Awlaki two weeks
after he was killed they also killed his
16 year old son in a drone strike and
they've never explained why they killed
the kid he wasn't with his daddy had
nothing to do with terrorism so the
first section I'm going to read is just
the prologue where I preview that part
of the story the young teenager sat
outside with his cousins as they
gathered for a barbecue he wore his hair
long and messy his mother and
grandparents have repeatedly urged him
to cut it but the boy believed that had
become his trademark
and he liked it a few weeks earlier he
had run away from home but not in some
act of teenage rebellion he was on a
mission in the note he left for his
mother before he snuck out the kitchen
window as the Sun was just rising and
headed to the bus station he admitted
that he had taken money from her purse
forty dollars for bus fare and for that
he apologized he explained his mission
and begged for forgiveness he said he
would be home soon the boy was the
oldest child and his family not just in
his immediate family which consisted of
his parents and his three siblings but
in the large house they shared with his
aunts and uncles and cousins and two of
his grandparents he was his
grandmother's favorite when guests
visited he would bring them tea and
sweets when they left he would clean up
after them once his grandmother twisted
her ankle and went to the hospital for
treatment when she limped out of the
treatment room the boy was there to
greet her and make sure she got home
safely you're a gentle boy his
grandmother always told him don't ever
change the boys mission was simple he
wanted to find his father he hadn't seen
him in years and he was afraid that if
he didn't find him he would be left only
with blurred memories of his father
teaching him to fish to ride a horse
surprising him with an abundance of
gifts on his birthday taking him and his
siblings to the beach or to the candy
shop finding his father would not be
easy he was a wanted man there was a
bounty on his head and he had narrowly
escaped death more than a dozen times
that powerful forces in multiple
countries wanted his father dead did not
deter the boy he was tired of seeing the
videos of his father the painted him as
a terrorist and an evil figure he just
knew him as his dad and he wanted at
least one last moment with him but it
didn't work out that way three weeks
after he climbed out the kitchen window
the boy was outdoors with his cousin's
teenagers like him laying a picnic for
dinner beneath the stars it was then he
would have heard the drones approaching
followed by the whiz of the missiles it
was a direct hit the boy and his cousins
were blown to pieces all that remained
of the boy was the back of his head his
flowing hair still clinging to it the
boy had turned 16 years old a few weeks
earlier and now he had been killed by
own government he was the third US
citizen to be killed in an operation
authorized by the president in two weeks
the first was his father so the second
section that I wanted to read mmm deals
with a entirely different story in the
book it's about the President Obama's
policy in Afghanistan of escalating
night raids where special operations
forces kick down doors of homes and they
are looking for Taliban leaders or
al-qaeda leaders and many of these have
ended up being botched and so this is
from a section called one night in
Gardez Gardez is a is a city in
Afghanistan in Afghanistan I
investigated several botched night raids
in which it was clear that innocent
people had been targeted none of them
were more gruesome none of them was more
gruesome than what happened just outside
of guard des in Paktika province in
February of 2010 on februari 12 2010
Muhammad Shahabuddin had much to
celebrate he was a respected police
officer who had recently received an
important promotion becoming head of
intelligence in one of the districts of
Paktika province in Southeast
Afghanistan he was also the father of a
newborn son that night Dawood and his
family were celebrating the naming of
the boy a ritual that takes place on the
sixth day of a child's life the party
was taking place at their compound in
the village of Catawba a short distance
from guard as the capital of POC Tia
there were two dozen people at their
home for the celebration along with
three musicians we invited many guests
in n music diodes brother-in-law
Mohammed to hair told me when i visited
the family during the party people were
dancing our traditional dance the ataan
the surah budin family was not ethnic
Pashtun the dominant almost exclusive
ethnicity of the Taliban their main
language was diary many of the men in
the family were clean-shaven or war only
mustaches they had long opposed the
Taliban Dawood the police commander had
gone through dozens of us training
programs and his home was filled with
photos of himself with American soldiers
another family member was a prosecutor
for the us-backed local government and a
third was the vice chancellor at a look
University the area where they lived was
near a Taliban stronghold in the hakan
II network an insurgent group that the
United States alleged had close ties to
al-qaeda and Pakistan's ISI spy
organization had been staging attacks
against government and NATO forces so
when they began to notice something was
amiss outside of their home outside of
their compound the family feared it
might be a Taliban attack on their home
it was around 330am as the celebration
was winding down that the family and
their guests noticed the main light to
the compound had been shut down by some
outside party around that time one of
the musicians went into the courtyard to
use the outhouse and he saw lasers
scoping the grounds from the perimeter
the man ran back inside and told the
others dawood went out to see what was
happening to hair told me he thought the
Taliban had come that they were already
on the roof as soon as Dawood and his 15
year old son said he kula stepped out
into the courtyard they were both hit by
sniper rounds and fell to the ground the
family began hearing the voices of their
attackers some were shouting commands in
English some and others in pashtoon the
family suspected the attackers were
Americans panic broke out inside the
house all the children were shouting
dawood is dead Dawood is shot Dawood is
shot to hell recalled Dodds eldest son
was behind his father and younger
brother when they were hit when my
father went down I screamed he told me
everybody my uncle's the women everybody
came out of the home and ran into the
corridors of the house I sprinted to
them and warn them not to come out as
there were Americans attacking they
would kill them meanwhile deludes
brothers Mohammed's a hair and Muhammad
SAW bear tried to come to his aid when I
ran outside diode was laying here
Mohammed severe told me as we stood in
the dusty courtyard at the very spot
where delwood was shot we carried out
inside as diode lay bleeding out on the
floor in a hallway inside the compound
his brother saw hair said he was going
to try to stop the attack by speaking to
the Americans he was a local district
attorney and newsom English we work for
the government he shouted outside look
at our police vehicles you've wounded a
police commander three women from the
family BB suleja age 37 BB Shireen age
22 and goole le aged 18 clutched at
Sahara's clothes pleading with him not
to step outside it didn't make a
difference
Sahara was gunned down where he stood
with sniper rounds hitting him in the
three women is a hair BB suleja BB
Shireen died quickly cool alien dude
held on for hours but they're besieged
family members could do nothing for them
and they eventually died from their
injuries somehow in a matter of minutes
a jubilant family event had become a
massacre seven people had died in all
according to the family members two of
the women had been pregnant the women
had 16 children among them it was 7am a
few hours earlier muhammad zubair had
just seen his brother his wife his niece
and his sister-in-law gun down now he
stood shell-shocked above their corpses
in a room filled with American soldiers
the mask commandos had burst into the
home and proceeded to raid at searching
every room Sabra told me that Dawood &
goo lolli was still alive at that point
u.s. soldiers kept saying they would get
the medical attention they didn't let us
take them to the hospital and kept
saying that they have doctors and they
would take care of the injured folks he
said I kept asking them to let me take
my daughter to the hospital because she
had lost a lot of blood and we had a car
right there muhammad tahir goo Lilly's
father recalled but they didn't let me
take her to the hospital my daughter and
I were still alive we kept asking but we
were told that a helicopter is coming
and that our injured will be taken to
the hospital both of them died before
any kal helicopter came to retrieve them
even as the American raid was underway
Mohammed severe and his nephew is that
along with the wives of Dawood and
severe prepared burial shrouds for those
who had died the Afghan custom involves
binding the feet and head a scarf
secured around the bottom of the chin is
meant to keep the mouth of the deceased
from hanging open they had managed to do
this before the Americans began
handcuffing them and dividing the
surviving men and women into separate
areas several of the male family members
told me that it was around this time
that they witnessed a horrifying scene
US soldiers digging the bullets out of
the women's bodies they were putting
knives into their injuries to take out
the bullet severe told me I asked him
bluntly you saw the Americans digging
the bullets out of the women's bodies
without hesitation he said yes tie her
told me he saw the Americans with knives
standing over the bodies they were
taking out the bullets from their bodies
to remove the proof of their crime he
said
Zoey Wickham it's probably unseemly to
read fiction after that but anyway that
goes i'm reading from from a novel
called David's story where half to two
narratives interwoven the first is of
David it's 1994 and it's the story of
David who is an ex commander in the
military wing of the ANC and the other
from which I'm going to read now is of a
minor Greek word chief at the beginning
of thing of the 20th century Adam [ __ ]
the first begat Cornelius [ __ ] the
Achilles who even after his death lost
the diamond fields of Greek will and
West who begat Adam [ __ ] the second who
begat Adam [ __ ] the third who more or
less begat Adam ace [ __ ] all without the
interference of women which was just as
well or the staff of office bequeathed
by the colonial government and
responsibly passed on from generation to
generation would undoubtedly have
consoled by a faithless wife but women
and complication will intrude and thus
are the mace Kochba got a daughter
Rachel Susannah was sitting on the knee
of Captain Atom [ __ ] the third listened
to marvelous and greatly exaggerated
stories about noon utter TC the giant
but aqua warrior chieftain s and
Victoria the small fat and cross British
Queen bewitched by the child the captain
said why not if she were good and quiet
and obedient why not a female successor
her father had a mace whose name in any
case did not
well could keep an eye on things until
she was ready to rule to which the
captain's chair bound lady nodded
vigorously having thrilled if the tales
of female rule she came to think of the
child is a very own when Adam ace [ __ ]
while sleeting the Greek were abelian in
eighteen seventy eight against British
annexation was shot by a dashing hi
commish nine a scarlet coat old lady
[ __ ] left more nimbly than a figure
would allow out of her chair to assume
the heavy staff of office which despite
the shaking of beards and grizzled heads
she held with a steadfast hand over her
people Rachel Susanna [ __ ] growing up in
the shadow of her aunt forgot all about
the Destiny pronounced by the captain
until she married none other than Andres
lafleur the grandson of a queasy young
you got Oh Eduardo Fleur was limp linen
clad figure we have left in an earlier
century insensible to the silver flying
fish at the equator as he stood before
meeting on the poop deck the rest of
Edward story can be found in mrs. Sarah
Gertrude melons narrative about
miscegenation although the reader should
note that she has taken several
liberties with a tail including casting
the boy as an Englishman and adding some
years to his age in other words that her
narrative is as unreliable as David's on
the autumn equinox of 1867 when Andres
laflare shot head fasting to the world
the cry of the departing stalk was quite
drowned by the scream of omagh trader
the Midwife the good woman at once
before delivered a cold baby years ago
in Greek island west and that one's
legendary powers division had not stood
him in good stead but such a cool like a
stocking pulled tightly over the little
ones head as if he could not risk
entering the world without a gorilla's
disguise amateur a disk
awful scissors trembled as she removed
the membrane but like baby Jesus the
infant uttered not a single cry po-faced
like his implacable grandfather she
might as well have left him imprisoned
in his call for all he seemed to care
about the world not that he was not
alert the mixture of malayan Madagascan
slave blood french missionary and coy
son Hunter blood had produced a perfect
blend of high cheekbones bronzed skin
and bright green almond eyes that stared
with such knowledge that his mother
whose name no one remembers wept and
turned away the nameless women trusted
no one not after the lies and the loss
of land the interminable trekking and
the bad manners of the British she was
supposed to be their saviors as for
expectation well she had learnt her
lesson in Grigor and west that it was
only sensible to stand such a thing on
its head and weightier opposite no
matter how old the legend of the call
the world was becoming horribly modern
and she would not believe that it would
bring her son good luck against death by
water the Midwife insisted sailors would
give you anything for such a call now
that's just the sort of good luck you
need when you live miles inland the
mother retorted did I not see with my
own eyes how you had to cut this blue in
the face baby out of captivity and now
look at him the baby's old man eyes
narrowed into points of green light
hardest diamonds bury the thing and
afterward to a SE lo anyone else said
the mother oma trader had to agree
classy 14a first call child in Hopetown
could see right through the earth to
where the diamonds lake glittering in
the deep and what fortune or hope did
that bring him led as he was by the
collar like a sniffer dog to show white
people where to dig and he's pot-bellied
children running around bear bummed with
nothing to eat if anyone
should ask about undresses score they
would simply denied under ease unlike
other children did not like playing with
water some say that it stemmed from the
day of his christening when old Domini
York Joshua's trembling finger missed
the font insensible to moisture the
horny digit traced a perfectly dry cross
on the baby's brow on reaching home his
mother reading an omen in the accidental
lack of water gave him a sprinkling that
even the indomitable infant could not
withstand his stylist eyes filled with a
liquid to disperse the light is
toothless mouth gaped once twice
resisting before he gave in to a hearty
whale it was then through snot and tears
that he heard the first voice fear and
neither water nor the absence of water
listen to the waves lapping at Robben
Island and look to the radical moisture
of the desert where your acquire
ancestors tended their stock the voice
that it first sounded incomprehensible
was in fact in Harry the old Greek were
tongue which then was spoken only by the
older generation that he was able to
access the language came as no surprise
the mixing of blood may have been old
hat in the melting pot of the Cape what
the infant Lafleur jerilyn arms
understood was that above the new raw of
eugenics the coy oldest blood of all
spoke at once most clearly and encode
and that the imperative its preferred
mood made for its clicking clarity
stephen adly Girgis hello this is uh it
really is amazing it really is amazing
um i would i would like to read a
portion of a scene called from a play
called in arabia we'd all be kings and
then i'd like to read a short or a
monologue from another play called Jesus
out to a chain so this play is set in a
bar in Times Square before it was
gentrified and and before the people and
the and the places were removed so this
there's three characters there's a
there's skank who's a junkie and a
hustler who's but a little bit past his
you know Prime and his girlfriend who's
also an addict who's a hooker named
chickie and then there's a guy named
Greer who comes in the bar and he's kind
of slumming and so read a little bit of
it yeah okay so Greer says it was
different then I get your man you get
him there chickie he's talking about it
was different then I got a friend
Franklin I call him up friday night and
this is important it's Friday night ok
Friday night now monday-friday oh I need
a drink barman I'll have another please
with a twist this is not a twist this is
a wedge twist good wedge bad okay you
want to drink sure barman one for him
how about chickie can she have one too
she looks a little young people say I
look young but then when they see me up
close they say I don't look so young as
they thought I was before they saw me up
close right fine
ever give her a drink so anyway I call
up my friend Franklin Franklin it's been
so long blah blah blah i miss you i miss
you too we should get together i was
just thinking of you lot a lot a lot so
i say where are you going out tonight
now let me tell you something about
Franklin back in the day if you wanted a
party just look for Franklin because I
don't care if it's the dentist night of
the week if you find Franklin you're
going to find a party and a damn good
one too I'm talking about the funhouse
peppermint lounge the old density Rhea
I'm talking about the limelight when the
limelight was the limelight I'm talking
about studio 54 I'm talking about doing
blow with Mick Jagger and miss Liza
Minnelli till 8am in the back of the
limo and someone's grabbing on you you
knew you know what and someone's
got--someone's tongue and someone
something and everyone is feeling it you
hear what I'm saying it's a [ __ ]
party oh lord have mercy but it was so I
says to Franklin I said what you doing
tonight girl he says I swear to God if
I'm lying I'm dying he says well career
I'm making a pot of tea and watching the
Blue Lagoon I said creature from the
Blue Lagoon he said no Brooke Shields
and christopher atkins Blue Lagoon I
said come on girl turn off that TV let's
do it like we used to he starts talking
about a a this jogging that and do I
want to go to a meeting you hear what
I'm saying that's rough man [ __ ]
i started talking about the Lord you
feeling me [ __ ] I mean when a man starts
talking about the Lord well I was raised
Baptist i have heard absolutely all i
need to ever hear about the damn Lord
you won't talk to me about the Lord you
better be the damn Lord otherwise is get
out of my kitchen girl goes breakfast is
definitely over I mean am I wrong nah
man I mean everybody I know is the same
[ __ ] eh eh nada GA nae many [ __ ] a
I'll show your mother [ __ ] falling for
it you know they got a support group for
people who think they're getting too
much sex I mean please have you ever
known a man gay straight whatever have
you ever had anybody ever come up to you
talking about oh man I'm just getting
too much booty and the more booty I get
the more miserable I am [ __ ] please
always ridiculous it's the Preston is
what it is used to be you take
for instance everyone could go out have
a good time now [ __ ] these [ __ ] I
work with all I want to do is drink one
light beer and we're one [ __ ] pissing
go home and shave the damn bodies and
pump iron and eat our falfa sprouts and
meditate and watch that damn Calista
Flockhart Skinny [ __ ] show you ever
seen that show yeah [ __ ] that show man
I'll tell you right now I never saw the
show and I never will I got better
things to do with my time to watch some
skinny [ __ ] being a skinny [ __ ] pardon
my language but that's how I feel and I
don't need the Lord to tell me how to
feel or what to watch and Christopher
Atkins notwithstanding I will eat a damn
[ __ ] before I stay home on Friday night
making tea and watching the damn Blue
Lagoon oh I need a drink and I need a
smoke cuz I'm working up a sweat here
wut you smoking just seeing its really
that's like the fun part of C and then
it gets kind of bad okay so this is just
a monologue basically from Jesus hop to
a chain and this basically the scene
there's a an older prisoner who's uh
what's it called not a psychotic a
crazy-ass serial killer a sociopathic
serial killer who's awaiting extradition
of Florida where he killed eight people
in prison he's found God and there's
another prisoner there on a 23-hour
lockdown so they have an hour today an
hour a day in these cages up on the roof
and there's this other young prisoner
who's just gotten in was very green and
very terrified and so the older prisoner
Lucius gets it into his head that if he
can minister and save this younger
inmate then he in turn will be saved as
the play goes on what happens to Lucius
is he still gets extradited to Florida
he realizes he's going to die and he
abandons all the religious [ __ ] because
unfortunately well it's the whole
conversation about sociopath
personalities but anyway this is Lucius
trying to minister
to this to this kid angel so he says uh
okay so listen careful there i was miami
beach paradise right little apartment
complex they got over there second floor
view of the ocean the ladies everything
the ladies down in Miami Beach angel mmm
like nobody's business brother awesome
incredible rent was cheap didn't pay
about 400 bucks a month in a little
place did I mention it had a little
Terrace well it did never went out on it
cocaine in Florida plentiful Jack
extremely plentiful and cheap real cheap
dirt cheap for all intents and purposes
the [ __ ] was free pardon my language but
that's what cocaine is [ __ ] horse [ __ ]
anyway oh and then quaaludes and little
74 teens like take an aspirin baby take
to call me late for dinner heroin dalada
just pick up the phone 30 minutes home
delivery hated the son no hated it I'm
not talking about gee I wish it wasn't
so sunny I'm talking hate pathological
Dracula's [ __ ] deep come a time I
stopped going to work if it was too
sunny used to call in sick order a pizza
in a 12 pack for 850 how you gonna be
dad delivery boy he was all right little
Ecuadorian kid used to pick me up little
something on the way nice bag couple of
pornos whatever I wanted used to come
blow little smoke with him he'd leave
happy nice little system one day he
stopped by I killed him killed him with
a cowboy boot I mean I was wearing the
boot at the time that that's how I
killed him after I killed him I didn't
know what to do so I chopped him up and
I throw them in the dumpster right next
door next door can you imagine that and
you know what happened nothing not a
damn thing kept waiting for the sirens
they never came so I called up the pizza
shop told him I never got my pizza you
know what they did they sent me another
one for free now to me let's peculiar
turn of events don't you think
unnatural now I'll tell you why I killed
him I killed him because he left the
door open said the place stock needed
some air but when the air came in Sun
came with it I think I think that was a
very unusual thing for me to do killing
that boy don't you highly unusual and
nothing happened nothing one day I
finally got up the gumption to leave
Miami but by then I killed five people
five killed three more up north over
here but they was all white funny how
people start paying attention when white
folks start chopping and all of this
because I hated the son my enemy the Sun
I had everything in the world down there
but I didn't have nothing now I got
nothing but I got everything I love the
Sun now love it before hey now love
that's a conundrum Kemosabe when you get
back to your cell don't lie down when
you can't do nothing except lie down
then you're going to lie down dig on
what I just told you reflect every hour
on my bank my walk my hand on the wall
three times let you remember you ain't
alone okay yeah hold up today's Monday
right is it yeah yeah don't take that
soup you'll be up all night thank you
adina hoffman to think that the Sun rose
in the east that men and women were
flexible real alive that everything was
alive to think that you and I did not
see feel think nor bear our part to
think that we are now here and bear our
part that is Walt Whitman a poem called
to think of time and this is me that the
book is from this is from my happiness
bears no relation to happiness the house
is dark in the februari damp but when
she opens the door to let me in M Nizar
is laughing it seems to tickle her that
I got lost on my way to the home she
almost never leaves and that after
driving and Confused loops around a
dingy nazareth neighborhood where
teenagers tinker with half stripped cars
and packs of chickens scuttle i gave up
pulled to the side and called to ask for
help in fact m nizar appears to be
giggling or at least grinning much of
the time the still girlish plains of her
grandmotherly face opened out into a
permanent amused high beam and though
she's sneezing and coughing today as she
greets me in her long terry cloth robe
and two cardigan sweaters her head
swelled in a loosely knotted wool scarf
she waves me over the threshold and into
the chill of the large living room with
such insistent good cheer Allen Lane the
standard welcome transformed in her full
throated delivery into a kind of credo I
feel like a traveller returning home
after a long and arduous journey never
mind the fact that my trip is really
just beginning this morning I packed
myself and my new tape recorder into a
shiny rental car and trundled westward
the north from Jerusalem past the year's
first almond blossoms and toward this
frigid room in beer ellimere the well of
the prince the nazareth neighborhood
where taaha Muhammad Ali and his family
have lived for more than 20 years the
approach to this house always entails a
subtle recalibration
a gentle almost unconscious readjustment
of one's pulse and gaze in this case the
gnawing drive i've just taken through
the traffic-clogged center of the
country and into congested downtown
nazareth began to fall away when I at
last regained my bearings and turned
down the steep hill that leads into the
neighborhood not that the scene there
was in any way past arola or uplifting
the entry is marked by an ugly clot of
concrete apartment buildings painted in
fading shades tan cream sickly yellowish
and gray one with a pink confectionery
stripe around the side and each with
laundry flapping despite the obvious
crowding that this knot of structures
implies the place is always oddly quiet
olive trees and vegetable gardens
interrupt the cement at sudden intervals
and several forgotten looking
construction sites have themselves
become prolific beds of plush grass and
wildflower for all the years i have
known Taha the space across the street
from his house has been dominated by the
skeleton of a massive apartment building
to be and his unfinished monstrosity
with its abandoned cement mixers and
heaps of litter strewn dirt as by now
almost come to seem a natural feature of
the landscape like a cliff face or
ancient Boulder taha's own house is
something else altogether in the context
of this dreary block the first sign that
one is now in the proximity of serious
imagination invisible from the road the
driveway leads into the heart of a thick
grove really a small forest of fruit
trees orange lemon grapefruit olive
pomegranate fig pecan and tangerine
palmela and almond and more olive all
planted close prickly pear rose jasmine
oleander geranium potato vine chicory
daisy and narcissus also cram the plot
as do swarms of apparently ecstatic
blackbirds and sparrows though I knew
from past visits that this lush and
singular orchard awaited me Emerald City
like at the end of my drive all the
foliage and sweet scent and birdsong
surprised me today nonetheless the
effect was it when stirring and calming
I would be content to sit in this
thicket of color all day but it is Tahu
I've come to see and after making my way
up the bougainvillea drenched staircase
to the second floor entrance and being
whisked in door
by the laughing em knees are to his wife
I am assured without much pomp into the
bedroom the only heated space in the
house where Taha is lying down and now
it is my turn to laugh at the sight of
him prone in a puffy full-length quilted
robe of gold tinted synthetic leopard
skin with long purple tassels and a
two-inch-thick calico lining my children
call it Gorbachev Taha announces a bit
cryptically then explains with Matt
grandeur that the garment is cirque
Asian a gift from a friend after taha
tripped and broke his leg in the living
room a few months earlier and the doctor
ordered him after an operation to stay
warm he wears it today over an old
running suit and with his usual black
pancake cap tilted at a rakish angle and
though his outfit is absolutely
ridiculous it does in its peculiar way
suit him equal parts clown and king i
should say i was there that day for a
complicated set of reasons some of which
were playing to me at the time and some
of which only became clear later but all
of which amounted to the fact that I had
basically decided our sort of felt
myself compelled to write the life and
times of this man held the palestinian
poet to ha Muhammad Ali it was in many
ways a completely insane thing to do
Taha was not and is not to this day a
household name in even in Arabic
speaking circles to try and tell his
story to english-language readers who
know very little of Palestinian culture
and even less about arabic literature
was going to be a serious challenge to
say the least Taha came from a village
called saphiria in the Galilee which
Israel demolished in the wake of the
1948 war and most of his poems almost
all of his poems well up from the ground
of that bulldozed place which is to say
that most of the history I would be
attempting to recount had been buried if
not completely erased and when you add
to that the fact of who I am a Jew who
carries two passports one American one
Israeli it may sound vaguely delusional
but I still I still felt compelled to
try given the cultural and political
climate that we were living in
it seemed critical to at least try or as
I put it in the book one of the
questions that I'm eager to answer as I
grapple with Taha'a life and its times
concerns his unlikely exuberance I have
seen so many people on both sides of the
ostensible palestinian-israeli divide
becomes sour depressed shrill stunted a
land that devours its inhabitants is the
eerily dead on biblical diagnosis how I
have wondered despite everything that
taaha has endured does he manage to
remain so alert and joyful if he has
been angry and his poetry acknowledges
that at times he has he has not let this
anger flare into hatred but he's turned
it into an art and a generosity of
feeling that almost that seemed almost
to defy history and maybe geography as
well his poetry has come to embody the
essence of this place addressing as it
does the most difficult in painful
dimensions of what is known as the
conflict at the same time it also
reaches far beyond these borders to
speak both to those who know the land
intimately and to those on the opposite
ends of the earth it is profoundly local
and utterly universal esta himself once
explained in my poetry there is no
Palestine no Israel but there are
suffering sadness longing fear and these
together make Palestine in Israel so
once I had decided to attempt to account
for that exuberance of his I still had
my work cut out for me and I'll end with
this venturing to reconstruct the years
of Taha'a childhood and adolescence or
to imagine saphiria in all its vanished
richness and complication is a daunting
task and as I work interviewing
translating and transcribing those
interviews sifting through archival
files combing footnotes and card
catalogs xeroxing looping microfilm on
two spools pouring through old journals
and newspapers I sometimes feel myself
an archaeologist entrusted with an
especially precious but partial and
vulnerable to the elements mound of
chipped relics and fragmented memories
each of which must be examined and
gingerly placed in a pattern that makes
some kind of sense
there are obstacles saphiria was an
almost entirely oral place and written
documentation of the village of the sort
biographers tend to take for granted
when constructing timelines and
portraits of their subjects simply does
not exist the village had no local
newspaper no records office no medical
files no school yearbook none of Taha'a
relatives or friends kept date books or
Diaries or wrote newsy letters to
out-of-town aunts his mother hung no
smiling wedding pictures from her walls
and she did not memorialize her
children's growth in a scrapbook or
photo album and whatever private papers
of Taha'a that might once have existed
his report cards his first attempts at
writing the singular the single
photograph taken of him as a child were
destroyed when the village was destroyed
the only paper trail left by the village
is a thin fascinating and distinctly
misleading one which passes through
archives now housed in Israel in England
these records provide a glimpse into the
life of the village that is on the one
hand marvelously concrete not precarious
and shifting like memory and so an
exciting discovery for someone trying to
rebuild the village as it were on the
page the tabletop sized mandate era and
Nazareth district police station logs
that have survived the years for
instance offer the most tangible facts
about the people in pulse of the village
who bullied who who cheated who who
beamed who over the head with a rock at
exactly what our on what day but as
these few examples indicate and his
logic dictates the only sort of events
that are preserved in the law
enforcement files are the grumbling ugly
ones this is merely a story of
grievances and arrests and though the
tale told by these records is no doubt
true and important to account for
somehow as one tries to conjure the
village it also leaves out the contented
day in day out uncomplaining side of
saphiria and according to the people who
live there this was the place they knew
and loved
in our last reader tonight james salter
Oh Phillip Bowman in his 20s he's an
editor a small publishing house in New
York met a girl from who lived in
Washington named Vivian and fell madly
in love with her and this is a part when
he takes her home to meet his mother
he's very interested in her before that
the Virginia of Vivian amison was Anglo
privileged and inbred he was made up of
rolling wooded country beautiful country
Richard heart with low stone walls and
narrow roads that had preserved it the
old houses were stone and often one-room
deep so the windows on both sides could
be opened and allow a breeze to come
through in the hot summers originally
the land had been given in royal grass
huge tracts before the Revolution and
put deforming tobacco first and then
dairy in the 1920s or 30s paul mellon
who liked to hunt came and bought great
amounts of land and friends joined him
and bought places from themselves it
became a country for horses and hunts
the hounds bein and disorders as they
ran while after them from around the
trees came the galloping horses and
their riders jumping stone walls and
ditch
is uphill and down slowing the little
galloping again it was a place of order
and style the kingdom from middlebury
Tuberville a place in life apart much of
it intensely beautiful the broad fields
soft in the rain are gentle and brighten
the Sun in the spring were the races the
Gold Cup in May over the steeplechase
Hills the crowd distractedly watching
from the rows of parked cars with food
and drink laid out in the fall were the
hunts that went on into the winter until
februari when the ground was hard in the
streams frozen everyone had dogs if you
had named a hound he or she was yours
when no longer needed for the hunt in
fact the dog would be dumped at your
door the fine houses belonged to the
rich and to doctors and the estate's
farms as they were called retained their
old names people knew one another those
they did not know they regarded with
suspicion they were white Protestant
with an unstated tolerance for a few
Catholics in the houses the furniture
was English and often antique passed
down through the family it was horses
and golf you made your best friends in
sport they go to summit which is
Bowman's town to meet his mother
Beatrice had been eager Demeter and was
also struck by her looks though in a
different way the freshness and naked
animal statement how much one knows from
the
first she had bought flowers and set the
table in the dining room where they
seldom aid usually using a table in the
kitchen one end of which was against the
wall the kitchen with shelves but no
cabinets was the real heart of the house
together with the sitting room where
they often sat in front of the fireplace
talking and having a drink now was now
there was this girl with somewhat stiff
matters she was from Virginia and
Beatrice asked what park middleburg well
we really nearly we really live nearer
to upperville Vivian replied upperville
it sounded rural and small it was in
fact small there was one place to eat
but no town water or sewage nothing had
changed there for a hundred years and
people they alighted that way whether
they lived in an old house without heat
or in a thousand acres upperville in the
country and beyond was an exalted name
the emblem of a proud parochial class of
which Vivian was a member you could not
stay there you had to live there it's
beautiful country bone was explained
Beatrice said I'd love to see it what
does your family do their farm the vin
said well my father for him some but he
also puts his fields up for grazing must
be big oh it's not terribly big it's
about 400 acres that's so interesting
apart from farming what is there to do
daddy always says there's lots to do he
means looking after the horses horses
yes
it's not that she was difficult to talk
to but you immediately felt the limits
Vivian had gone to junior college
probably at the suggestion of her father
to keep her out of mischief she had a
certain confidence based on the things
she absolutely knew and what she proved
to be enough like all mothers like all
mothers Oh bill just hoped for a girl
like herself with whom she could speak
easily and his view of life could
perfectly be confined combined with her
own among her pupils over the years she
could think of girls who are like that
good students with natural charm that
you admired and were drawn to but there
are also others not so easily understood
and his fate you were not meant to know
didn't liz Bohannon come from middleburg
Beatrice asked bringing up a name a
horse and society figure of the 30s
always photographed with her husband was
some [ __ ] sailing to Europe or in their
box at Saratoga yeah she has a big place
she's a friend of my father's she's
still around oh very much around there
are a lot of stories about her Vivian
said when they first bought their place
long tree that was the name then she
used to ride in from the hunt and let
the dogs come right into the house they
jump up on the table and eat everything
after she got divorce she calmed down a
bit oh you must know her then oh yes the
VN was eating somewhat carefully not
like a girl with a genuine appetite
the flowers which Beatrice had moved to
the side or a lush backdrop for her some
young pagan goddess who cast a spell
over her son though it wasn't entirely a
spell day after said in a way to measure
how much in need of love he was and what
forms that took meanwhile he was
absolutely certain of one thing and he
would never meet someone like Vivian
again he saw himself tumbled with her
among the bed clothes and fragrance of
married life the meals and holidays of
it the shared rooms the glimpses of her
half dressed her blondeness the pale
hair were a legs Matt the sexual riches
that would be there forever and when he
told his mother he hoped to marry her
Beatrice though afraid it would prove
nothing protested how unalike the two of
them were how little they had in common
that a great deal in common Bowman a
little defiantly said what they had in
common was more vital than similar
interests it was wordless understanding
and accord what Beatrice did not say but
what she deeply felt was that Vivian had
no soul but to say it would be
unforgivable she merely SAT silent after
a moment she said I hope you won't rush
into anything in her heart she feared in
her heart she feared she knew the things
you cannot see when you are too young
she hoped there was a little time the
infatuation would pass she can only
press his head against her in love and
understanding I only want you to be
happy truly happy I would be truly happy
I mean in your deepest heart yes in my
deepest it was love the furnace into
which everything is dropped